abigail is in orlando starting off this
hour
hi abigail how are you hey dave i'm
doing good thanks for taking my call
today
sure what's up so i have been
saving up during forbearance period
because i just graduated in may and i
have
over 140 grand and loans good lord
are you a doctor or a lawyer nope i am a
first generation college student who
didn't realize what i was getting into
going to a private university
um down in west palm beach so now i'm
aware
but uh i got a computer science degree
so hoping that that will at least
help me somewhat to be able to
absolutely have you landed the
the tech job yet yes i've been working
since september and uh actually a
company down
in palm beach gardens um so i'm working
there i've been working here for a while
so it's been a good fit
what are you making uh 67 right now
good good and that's your first job out
of college that's nice good
so you got a good you got a good
information systems or technology degree
for four years computer science degree
and that sets you up to uh you know to
if if you will keep reading studying
and stay cutting edge in the tech world
your income's going to double in the
next three to five years
yeah and that's my point i'm working on
some certificates right now yes um for
security so that's
yes excellent well it'll more than
double if you go into that side
yes yes the hottest one of the hottest
segments in all of technology right now
very well done that's a good choice
thank you and i have some
managerial experience from college too
so hoping that'll
help boost possibly management and cyber
security but today i was just calling
because i've
had some friends recently been uh saying
i should be saving for a down payment uh
her house in florida since
yeah your friends
you don't need taking financial advice
for broke people you have 140 000
in student loan debt that's a crisis you
got to get rid of that
yeah that's what i was thinking too but
i was my mom said you should call dave
ramsey so i was like okay mine is
well your mom your mom set you up
mom's mom's got some sense mom set you
up she knew what i was going to do to
you that's right
she's like friends are giving bad advice
let me send her to the guy
listen yes yeah you need some r r you
need some
roommates and rent not buying a house
you need roommates
and you need rent cheap rent while you
pay off this debt
that's the focus and if you get gazelle
intense like we talk about you put those
blinders on
and focus on you will knock it out you
will knock it out and then you can save
her house and do all those fun things
but
right now this is that's a huge thing to
weigh you down especially so early in
life
did you buy a car yeah um i
it's completely paid off i did buy a car
but i it's paid off completely so
good what's it worth it is when i bought
it it was 17
and that was two years ago it's a family
so i'm
hoping it'll last a while so r r
christie's right so here's the thing
if i woke up in your shoes you got
nothing but huge potential
and the main roadblock to you being
very very wealthy in the next 15 years
is these stupid student loans
and so you got to treat them like they
are the enemy
and they must be destroyed they are the
evil empire
yeah and we get mad every morning when
we get up at student loans
and give sally mae her eviction notice
out of your life so let's play with some
numbers okay
you live on nothing you take all the
extra gigs you can get in the technology
field
and if you put 50 000 a year
you're on student loans you're done in
three years
now 50 out of 67 doesn't work but your
income is going to be going up
and in the meantime you're going to get
cheap rent and roommates
and you're going to take extra jobs
until the income does come up
but i predict three years from now
you're going to be making a lot of money
if you'll keep on the security path and
keep doing this stuff and just work like
a maniac and put it all on this
because because you're what you're 23 or
22.
22. 22. so by the time you're 25 you're
debt-free
yeah now and you're making 110.
yeah now you can save for a house kiddo
yeah yeah definitely thank you so much
you guys i appreciate it thank you yeah
well done
are you going to do that oh yeah i
already actually have um
it's not iq but i'm i'm going to be
roughing on the side
just started are you going to go get out
of debt in three years like we talked
about
yes yes sir i am okay we're holding you
to it
i can't i can't wait to hear from you i
want to hear your debt-free scream on
that on the show okay
i will thank you so much guys alright
god bless you open phones at triple
eight eight two that felt a little too
easy um
if she if here's the thing if she starts
doing some freelancer doing some stuff
on the side
you can make some good money in the
technology field with what she knows and
what she can do
she can she can get that extra income up
asap
and she's used to living on nothing
she's broke college yeah she'll keep
leaving like a couple
she can dig out of that ditch real fast
yeah you don't have to run up seventy
thousand dollar lifestyle just because
you're making 70 000 at 22 years old
don't listen to your friends
who say you need to buy a house right
now
friends the friends the friends i love
it
if your broke friends are giving you
financial advice whatever they said to
do the exact opposite oh my gosh